Yemen is on the verge of total collapse
Saudi Arabia backed by the United States
is leading a military offensive in the
country their target Houthi rebels have
taken control of major parts of Yemen
and are allied with Iran Saudis regional
rival but does it boil down to a Saudi
irani and proxy war that everyone's
talking about it's actually much more
complicated there are so many different
groups competing for power and Yemen's
political chaos so we've narrowed down
four key players you should know about
let's start with the Houthis an armed
resistance group from North Yemen they
belong to the Zadie sect of Shia Islam
and they're a local group with local
grievances
those include years of economic social
and political marginalization complaints
of government corruption and opposition
to the Yemeni US alliance over the past
year the Houthis have taken control of
Yemen big time they seized the capital
Sana'a
drove out the president Abed Rabbo
Mansour Hadi from the presidential
palace and formed an interim government
they've also forged unlikely alliances
most notably with Yemen's former
president who once fought against them
Ali Abdullah Saleh when it comes to
Yemeni politics Ali Abdullah Saleh
is the ultimate survivor he survives
sanctions civil war assassination
attempts and political isolation Saleh
who was forced out of his presidency
following the so-called Arab Spring
after 33 years of dictatorship his Vice
President had he replaced him but even
though Saleh has no longer in office he
remains in Yemen and continues to be one
of the most powerful political players
behind the scenes Soloff was known to
crush any opposition to his rule and
waged war against various groups within
Yemen including the Houthis but guess
what Saleh had his army loyalists are
now fighting alongside them and that's
really angering Saudi Arabia who used to
back Saleh for Saudi Arabia Yemen
matters a lot the two countries share a
long unsecured border in addition to
tensions that have been ongoing since
the 1930s the reasons for those tensions
have varied but what has remained
constant is Yemen's strategic location
it sits right next to the Horn of Africa
and a major waterway that's used to ship
crude oil from the Middle East to Europe
and North America that's key for
political and economic influence and
that's why the kingdom has gone to great
lengths to ensure its friends are
running things in Yemen powerful Houthis
allied with regional rival Iran equals a
threat to that power Saudi Arabia has
accused Iran of meddling in Yemen by
providing weapons and fuel finally Saudi
Arabia wants to contain the threat of al
Qaeda in the Arabian Peninsula
it's the network's most lethal branch
which is based in Yemen Saudi wants to
make sure they don't cross the border
into the kingdom so where does the u.s.
fit into all of this for years Yemen was
a key ally in the u.s. fight against Al
Qaeda
not long ago President Obama even said
this this strategy of taking out
terrorists who threaten us while
supporting partners on the front lines
is one that we have successfully pursued
in Yemen and Somalia for years the u.s.
gave him in cash and weapons and in
exchange both of Yemen's former leaders
allowed the u.s. to wage its so-called
war on terror which included those
infamous drone strikes but that
counterterrorism strategy hasn't quite
worked the security situation in Yemen
has gotten so bad that the u.s. had to
evacuate its remaining 125 Special
Operations advisors and while the US
isn't directly participating in the
military campaign in Yemen Obama is
supporting the coalition of various
countries by providing logistics and
intelligence so where does it all go
from here one thing is for sure the
country's humanitarian crisis is only
getting worse and it's the people of
Yemen who are paying the ultimate price
[Music]